("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
Doing something a little bit
different with #BizDevSunday.
Gonna actually
air them on Sundays.
So excited about that.
Got some good ones for you this
week and also pretty excited
about what's been going on
with the ones we've been doing.
So excited, here they come.
Facebook video, very
important part of my world.
Obviously, put out a lot of
stuff on Facebook.com/Gary.
Looking for people who have big
Facebook pages that match the
kind of content that I put
out that want to put out
content on their page.
Biz dev Facebook.
You can see it right here.
There's a form,
just fill it out.
You don't need to
email the biz dev email,
bizdevsunday@VaynerMedia
that's not this.
If you have Facebook fan
page that is around motivation,
social media, business topics
or just was
inspired by some of the
stuff that I've done and wanted
to distribute some of my videos,
looking for content
distribution partners.
Fill out the form, leave in the
notes what you want in return
but I'm looking for an army of
50 to 5,000 Facebook pages that
when we have a kind of once in a
month video that I really think
I just want the world to see,
I want to have a team that wants
to natively distribute
it through their page.
There's a new little tweak
on that that we've noticed on
Facebook that we want to try and
do and so if you want to give
back a little love or if there's
something you want to trade that
kind of distribution
for I'm open ears.
GaryVee.com/BizDevFacebook
link right here.
Obviously, you're watching it.
Fill out the form
and we'll be in touch.
Getting serious about YouTube.
Very serious.
Really looking to
explode DailyVee through
the fuckin' roof. So
YouTube collaborations.
Obviously, I've been
saying no to most podcasts,
Rogan I did.
But if you've got
a big YouTube page,
call it 500,000 subs or higher,
please email me below if you
want to do a collaboration.
Come to New York or
if I'm in your area.
Doing a couple when
I'm in Salt Lake City,
Shonduras, looking
forward to it, brother.
500,000 subs or more on your
YouTube page and there's some
interesting way for us
to collaborate for me to
incorporate, let me know.
Email me below.
Looking forward to it.
So a lot of you know that
I bought PureWow (bell dings)
PureWow.com, one of the
leading female media websites.
I've also noticed on Instagram a
lot of 26 to 55-year-old female
is doing incredibly
interesting stuff with
their Instagram account.
Would love to collaborate.
Put in the title PureWow.
By the way, the last one put
in the title 500,000+ YouTube.
When you email these we
need to separate them so
please use it in the title.
Just put PureWow collaboration
looking for podcasters,
bloggers and definitely
Instagram and YouTube
influencers that are
really attacking that 25 to
45-year-old female demo.
See if we can do some really
cool stuff with the PureWow team
together on some fun
collaborations so check it out.
Also if you're in
to that kind content,
sign up for the newsletter,
PureWow.com mother fuckers.
Alright, this is
the ultimate one.
I'm excited about this one.
It's the ultimate
Biz Dev Sunday pitch.
Take a picture and post it on
Instagram or make a one minute
video and post it on Instagram,
use the hashtag #BizDevSunday,
the way I do it B-I-Z and
tell me the biz dev that
you want to do. Pitch me.
We're gonna look at all of them.
Every picture,
no Instagram stories.
Main post, either picture or
one minute video pitch on the
business deal you
want to do with me.
What do you want, what do I get
and let's pick one random person
on Monday or
Tuesday to do the deal with.
So the ultimate
Biz Dev Sunday pitch,
pitch me on the deal.
What's the trade you
and I are gonna make?
Alright, hope you love Biz
Dev Sundays as much as I do.
Love you guys, have a
great rest of your weekend and
I will see you tomorrow.
(light music)